is now a good time to go to a coding
boot camp for me that answer is hello
everybody my name is Nyan I'm the black
female engineer I provide content for
new inspiring software engineers and
today we're going to talk about coding
boot camps is now a good time to go and
here let me make sure I make this clear
right now when I am talking about coding
boot camps in this sense I'm talking
about paid coding bootcamps boot camps
that cost over ten thousand dollars to
attend
oh
so first things first we cannot have
this conversation without having the
tech conversation in general I'm pretty
sure most of us have seen what's been
going on in the world of tech the
layoffs and just the decrease in stock
prices as well now I'm not saying this
to say that
right now is not a good time to become a
software engineer that's not what I'm
saying at all however when we're looking
at these Trends specifically the
decrease in stock prices that affects
the lucrative nature of the offer you
are likely to get when you do get a job
or an offer as a software engineer in
2022 the tech stock prices decreased by
30 percent
now this may not mean much to many
people I I feel like it should
especially if you're looking to enter
the space because
what is the number one thing most people
brag about when they're talking about
their tech jobs
money money
that's what people tout around that's
what they talk about when talking about
what made them get into the field and
why they love the field so much now
something that's not always uh shared
explicitly is where that money is coming
from many people if they work at Google
they work at Netflix Microsoft they will
brag about how much money they are being
paid and not not I'm not saying that the
bragging is wrong but what I am saying
is a lot of the money that they're
receiving in terms of in regards to
compensation comes from this thing
called stock options when 30 20 40 of
your compensation package is based off
of stock options and now you see that
stocks have decreased by 30 percent now
the value of those options have
decreased significantly as well making
the compensation package of a faint job
or Tech job in general just less
lucrative and just less desirable than
what it was in the past 2020 pre-2020
Etc now and I mentioned this in the
beginning I'm not saying this to say
that now is a bad time to become a
software engineer but why am I saying it
because coding boot camps expect you to
put up an investment of 10 12 15 20
000 for a couple of months of learning
with this uh almost promise that they
give you of hey but you're gonna get a
really lavish Tech job you're gonna get
a job that pays so much more than this
uh than this fee you just need to invest
in yourself and yes I am all about
investing in yourself but not when
that return on investment is different
now than it was a couple of years ago
and it very much is now that's just one
thing now let's talk about another thing
chat gbt is so amazing in that it has
the potential to help you go towards
your goals in a way that's just not been
seen before
if you saw my last video I talk about
how to become a software engineer in
four months in lightning speed using
chat GPT
chat gbt has allowed for extra guidance
to be received where before that
guidance was maybe only available behind
a pay wall I personally have said many
times that I believe the main reason a
person should make the decision to pay a
large sum of money for a coding boot
camp is because they want true guidance
from somebody who has
um who has experience in the field that
is why I went I had tried to go the
self-teaching route back in 2020 and it
just wasn't working for me because I
constantly did not know what the next
step to take was and it really just
hindered my learning and that's what
made me find say fine I'll go to a
coding bootcamp now however that's not
necessarily the case if I want guidance
I kind of have it check out that video
so you can really see exactly what I
mean but where before I would learn
something and I didn't know if I was at
a good place to learn something else or
what that next thing to learn even was
now chat gbt is able to spit out the
information for you in this so easy to
grasp and comprehend manner that
I don't really need uh to pay ten
thousand dollars to have somebody else
tell me how to do it now some of y'all
might be asking hey now but according
boot camps they might look better on my
resume or they'll help me get a job or
all these other reasons to go to a
coding bootcamp the thing is
and I hate say this I'm not trying to
call people a liar I'm not
coding boot camps don't really help you
get the job if you ask most people if
you ask me I still very much had to do
that all on my own they do Express that
they help through advisors through
counselors they have connections with
jobs to help you get interviews and
whatnot and that just wasn't what I saw
in my experience I'm going to the job
hunt process after spending 16 weeks
learning to code did not ever feel oh
thank God I went with the coding boot
camp because now I have all these
different job opportunities no so what
I'm saying is if you're going to be
doing all that work anyway and now you
have a way to receive guidance that
doesn't include a coding bootcamp
why not go The non-coding Bootcamp route
now chatgpt is a humongous resource that
all of us I can say have found some type
of benefit from away from chai gbt so
many more resources have come up in the
last couple of years since I have
started learning to code even though
that was just two and a half three years
ago oh my goodness that was three years
ago not even a half that was three years
ago but yeah so many more resources have
come up where if I want to go to a free
coding boot camp there are options for
me there's Ada Academy there's resilient
coders there's a hundred devs and all
these other resources that I'm going to
link below in the description box but
there's just so many more resources now
that it's not you're all on your own or
you must spend ten to twenty thousand
dollars on a boot camp there are Now
options in the middle and those options
are really good ones some of them so do
not skip past looking through those
options if you'd like me to do a video
on what those options look like please
let me know in the comment box below but
I see that to say
there's just so many more resources
y'all and another consideration I would
really appreciate you all making is the
added cost of the boot camp so coding
boot camps cost ten thousand dollars
fifteen thousand dollars twenty thousand
dollars many people don't just have that
to just give many people are taking out
loans to do that with interest rates
being as high as they are right now
coding boot camps if you pay for it via
a loan it's not just ten thousand
dollars it's not just fifteen thousand
dollars it's substantially more than
that now because of the high interest
you're paying on top of the loan itself
and to go back to my first point to do
all of that and on top of it the return
not be as lucrative as it was before
with what compensation packages looks
like now it's just another layer to
consider when trying to decide whether
or not to go to a paid coding Boot Camp
or not and so it's now a good time to go
to a coding boot camp for me that answer
is no I'm not saying it's never a good
time I'm not saying different
circumstances does not uh decide whether
or not it's a good time or not but given
what I've talked about here and the
resources that have come up in the last
few years on top of the financial weight
of the decision now as opposed to a
couple of years ago I would say
it is not a good time to just jump into
a coding boot camp I'm not saying don't
do it especially if you've tried
applying to the free options and you
just haven't gotten much luck there and
now it's okay I've gone through all the
options and this is the only one for me
because of the type of learner I am and
the situation I'm in then please do not
see this as me saying don't do it
especially when the options are go to a
coding boot camp and get a job or you
stay at a place in your life that you
don't want to be in and you've tried all
these different things it's been months
you've been trying to self-teach and do
all this it's just not working know that
that is not what I'm saying at all so I
hope this was helpful I hope it was
informative what questions do you have
let me know in the comment box below but
yeah thank you so much for joining me
for another video and I will talk to you
all very soon bye all